hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm John so let me give you guys a
little background on what's happening
right now it is past midnight for us I
get a little bit anxiety when I know big
trailers coming and I can't sleep so I
took a melatonin about 20 minutes ago
has yet to kick in so I'm going to use
the last energy left because this
trailer dropped exceptionally earlier
than I anticipated impossible fallout
people my most anticipated summer movie
that's right put it above ant-man in the
Worcester even though where it is Marvel
hat land you guys know that there's no
opening sketch for this if you guys
haven't seen our first reaction to this
trailer please go watch that is a
two-minute opening sketch that we
actually put a lot of work into on that
one so all of you guys go check that out
but yeah let's watch this second trailer
let's do it tell you guys there's time
to watch the first trailer like I catch
a lot in the theaters now
nipple chills through the roof a
marathon these films
don't be peace without first a great
suffering rate to the suffering the
greater the peace then you always fear
it's coming blood will be on your way
Wow
I prayed to go that it was true Solomon
Lane escaped in Paris
you use a scalpel I prefer he's not just
some observer he's an assassin mother
well there's not money outside in this
room
you go ro he's been authorized to hunt
you down and kill you
that's the job
no hard feelings
some words about it yeah stops boom
everyone I ever cared about you need to
walk away
[Music]
[Music]
do you really do that either
you've lost this one was done this time
what's done is done when we say it's
done show Todd oh my god whoa
says 10 says that last moment was I was
like it's kind of like you said in the
trailer
[Applause]
steak right this movie looks like it's
just gonna be a gigantic symphony of
actions yeah there's so many
hard-hitting moments from so many
different looking scenes and locations
and stuff the whole first talk with
Solomon Lane picking up exactly from
rogue nation interesting to see this
just this whole trailer because you know
you're getting Michelle Monaghan back
you're getting Rebecca Ferguson back
Ving Rhames and Simon Pegg are here and
then Solomon Lane was amazing villain
and rogue nation they're picking up
pretty much immediately after I like how
he's talking about this sort of global
destruction in a way and it's insane
it's all gonna fall a big weight to
carry yeah and these do seem like
impossible stakes
yeah whatever the consequence of this
even though he's got a bigger plan in
mind it seems like there's a sense of
revenge as well he does not look as good
as he did it's gotten personal it's got
to be personal I mean this whole thing
feels more personal if you're bringing a
villain back based off the heavy amount
of it for me yeah and it's trailer what
I got from it was Henry Cavill he's not
a bad guy like the way they're pitching
in terms like a submission man works for
the CIA is an assassin for them and he's
been tasked to take down Solomon Lane
and what they were quickly showing in
the trailer hubs called rogue once more
this is not a cure Ethan yeah off this
case that we got this and Ethan home
wants to take on the mission of course
he does and of course he's gonna do it
rogue because why not never on his side
why did they keep playing this yeah
because he goes rogue Henry Cavill has
to go after him as well or if he's there
I guess he has to take him down as well
which probably just leads into they're
gonna end up working together by the ya
know have like respect for our kind of
impossible mission because in the last
trailer - Henry Cavill even has a line
where it seems like he's being
understanding of Ethan Hunt where he's
talking something about how many times
says his country turned his back on him
oh do to a guy how many times has Hans
governments betrayed him disavowed him
cast him aside how long Henry Cavill
looks great I don't feel like they're
doing that jeremy renner thing they did
with ghost Protocol where you're like
terms the new guy and then you watch it
like alright who are you really
Brandt we all have our secrets I feel
like this one he's gonna really shine
yeah yeah cuz it seems like they're not
building him up to be any more or less
than he probably is in the movie now
just guessing but how much is going on
how many plot lines they've established
in this trailer alone got even on his
vision but then you got you know his
superiors with their clash right things
the team and things with Solomon Lane
for both of them and then this conflicts
he adds this is there are some images in
here that kind of confused me a little
bit because what are you saying he
hasn't trust anyone else in this room
Rebecca Ferguson is in that room Lisa
the trailer makes it look that way and
then they have a later moment where
she's like into kind of reminiscent of
her character a rogue nation or like
there's something much bigger at hand
yeah that's high to you it seems like
even this team is not fully cooperating
with him right now
yeah he's really going full-on rogue in
a lot of ways there's a lot of crazy
action scenes it looks like he's really
by himself or just Benji's by his side
hey now yeah I mean and that goes back
to you know him saying like - so in your
hands man like what that you know would
do to anybody I'm sure he's very
alienated from you at the moment there's
the the humor that comes up out of that
too you know like the friction that they
might be having the big sequence we're
in nowadays when you see a play of the
sequence you're like oh I know it's off
sure he's gonna really done that he's
jumping out of the plane it doesn't look
like a terrible CGI Don face it looks
like it could really be him jumping out
of that plane yeah I'm sure he'd what I
just don't yeah I'm not I'm not sure I
can't tell or maybe it's the kind of
thing where where they had to assist it
I don't know what kind of quality or you
get on a plane you know trying to get
Tom Cruise and space through the lit up
class yeah that was a great trailer yeah
that was really is really exciting the
first one I thought was a perfect
trailer because this pumps you up and
this one really pulls you in more to the
story in the plows going I think this is
good I think that I think yeah I wanna
watch this in IMAX
Exeter you guys put your comments down
below guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
Belka subscribe buttons don't really
work check us on patreon uploading a lot
over there full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A some other good vids as well
I think that hoe toting the 7 tickets
settle up you bet you gonna edit this
low in the morn